hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
this is Tamra just saw us the cameras
never seen intro maybe I should do
something different for this I wish I
could have something animate like the
rollercoaster beginning of all regal
movies like welcome to regal welcome to
you came I just saw a little bit of a
bum ba-bum ba-bum ba-bum so the splash
is a popcorn falls you know I'm talking
about know if you've not been to a regal
theater this is just crazy talk this is
a new series that I'm trying out that's
in a very similar vein to Tamara's never
seen so that I don't repeat the mistakes
of my past if you saw the Tamara's never
seen it was posted yesterday I saw John
wick and today actually last night I saw
John wick chapter 2 if you saw the
episode from last night you know that I
love you John wick so much you guys and
I thought it was going to be this
generic action film and it wasn't maybe
dogs dogs were a part of the movie
castra stellar the acting was stellar
the action was stellar and dog you guys
did I mention there's dogs in the film
so last night I was at the first viewing
of John Waite chapter two in my local
Regal theater which might notebook I
felt very official like writing notes
during a movie and I think the people
next to me were like why is she taking
notes of this action it's not that
in-depth girl I'm going to try to do the
spoiler free until the very end and then
I'll let you know spoilers are coming
like I said this is the first viewing at
my local theater and it got five
applause breaks and I said that on
Twitter people were like oh did they
stop the movie for you so that you could
break know you know I mean delight
people clap during the movies I really
like what other people are excited about
things because I'm often very excited
about singing the first thing I wrote
down is back in the game back in the car
back in the suit gapper a.m. there's a
lot of times to the first film obviously
it's the second film they do in a way
that's just so exciting and just like
plays into that like I know I saw the
movie two days ago but that is no big
thing but you want to see the elements
from the first you want to rewatch they
do it so well there's this killing
machine John wick the boogeyman who
kills I want to say
ah let's be conservative and say 250
people it's single handedly and you're
still laughing throughout the film
you're rooting for this character and
the character at the end still comes out
as this good man who you want to get a
burger with or a veggie patty your
preference I'm sure he'd be down for
both because he's a level-headed guy the
sun is shining I usually film this at
night the elements have betrayed me
the unfinished business that John has in
this film starts off as him just needing
to retrieve his car still okay I
understand this is your whole like
mission to you know avenge your wife and
and the dog and Daisy and all the stuff
but maybe just let the car go but then
there's a really great scene explaining
why he wanted the car and it's excellent
and this movie just such a good job of
like totally at your heartstrings while
also being this crazy death frenzy
there's so many points where his old
lifestyle pulls him back in and drags
him back in and it's like mint just let
this guy retire in peace like dooming to
buy a timeshare in Florida and just go
live his life with his cute Bulldog
pitbull pitbull the cast in this movie
is so good Ruby Rose isn't it she is the
best that was common yes okay all right
that's how I know that character
Laurence Fishburne resisted he was
awesome he was like this crazy bag lady
but Birdman awesome great character the
sequel was so strong and and there's
this thing about sequels that they're
you know never as good as the first and
I think that was so true years ago but
we're getting to the point where sequels
just can't be bad now for the most part
because if they are he's falling into
that trap and then then no one will see
it this was just as good it's not better
than the first in my opinion I loved it
there's another amazing party scene
with like strobe lights and loud music
biceps they're also ruining ancient Rome
buildings with gunshots but it scares so
you don't know what I'm referencing
right now but I wrote one of if not the
best hand-to-hand fights I've ever seen
in my life and it was between John and
common character that Colin plays a wild
Ike appears don't not go with my coffee
please
so a bunch of stuff happens and there's
another open contract out for John the
ten for seven million dollars and it's
just a really cool way they kind of end
it on that um and she says this awesome
line like I tell them I will kill
whoever comes for me I will kill them
all and she's like you're a monster and
I love you and it's so good it's so good
I enjoyed the heck out of this movie I
feel like I'm just in this whirlwind of
John wick for the past couple days
because I thought for Tamara's never
seen and then I saw this and they were
both so good and so hiked on the series
and I hope they make it three so bad
okay so I'm going to just do a couple
spoilers right here click away if you
don't want to see them I'm also going to
talk about some of the trailers two that
I saw that were incredible okay so in
the first big laugh of the movie we got
was of he's he's getting back his car
and he kills like thirty people in this
car garage ruined his car and there's
this one guy who's about to get it and
he shoots him it's both of Susie cast
the entire audience roared it was
horrific and hilarious also the best
callback of the movie was the pencil
scene in the first film and in a second
people bring up how he killed three guys
in a bar with a pencil and they actually
do that seems good there's a slow or
he's he's fighting all these guys um and
he doesn't have any bullets he sees a
pencil if everyone in the theater start
clapping it was so exciting I had so
much fun watching this movie with all of
these strangers who also
just love this character obviously his
house gets burned up to the ground by
this douche canoe guy so one of my
favorite parts is he's like passed out
and how she's got blown up he just got
like thrown out of his house and you're
like no no no no no no no big dog who
doesn't have a name also hilarious his
dog now and they made like the first
second they could if the dog comes up it
like licks his face he'll like oh my god
thank the Lord on high they did not kill
to talk again and I'm the second really
amazing thing that had to do with the
house being burned up is at the end he
takes care of his business in a very
epic way and then he goes back to the
house sees all the rebel there's nothing
left of his wife until he fishes out her
bracelet so he sold one things he lost
this video he lost all the photos he's
got she's got her bracelet and that's
really so nice what a cool thing and he
just had only at that amount of time to
get the bracelet and then he had to go
back and take care of some more things
that was really nice
it's like such good story and you care
so much about this guy okay that's all
the spoilers I'm gonna do though but god
I enjoyed the heck out of this movie was
so so good I wrote dapper like 20 times
and I know Stella like that is the word
but that is the word
so the trailers were awesome I just want
to touch on them really fast
trailers are now like these little mini
epics that if it doesn't capture you in
the first two seconds you like I don't
care I want to see it too that I hadn't
heard anything about is live by night
with a high road batman Affleck and then
free fire with brie Larson those look
awesome and I had not heard anything
about those that will definitely be
seeing those okay okay I want to touch
on the Fast and the Furious franchise
I've not seen one fast and furious movie
so the new ones called the fate of the
Furious and I wrote I roll it looks so
cheesy but also it looks like it would
be a blast to watch maybe I should do
like a marathon video of me watching
those movies I don't know but I loved in
Diesel a lot so maybe I'll just love
them maybe I just haven't tapped in to
this love of action film that I just
didn't know that I had then I wrote holy
crap comical island looks
amazing and has amazing people in it and
I cannot wait to see that film I'll
probably do that for another episode of
camera just dogs ah I look so good it
also looks like a great comedy in it too
so I just ah yes
um Logan so pumped for Rogen I can't
wait the girl and that looks so good
she's like what she looks like she's
seven or eight oh she looks so good God
in her fight off ah and I'll wait for
that film powering Power Rangers look
Power Rangers looks so cheesy and I
cannot wait to see it
I grew up watching Power Rangers movies
I guess until I was like around ten like
the last time I remember watching them
but my brother nice dressed up like the
Power Rangers and run around our house
of jump off of crap so and then the last
one was the Tupac movie that I have not
heard anything about it looks awesome
I am super excited to see this but yeah
guys that was Tamara just uh if you have
any suggestions on how to make this
series better let me know um this is the
first time I guess it's still a reaction
video I stand by my word like I am NOT I
don't do reviews this is like just my
reaction to this so um I don't say that
in a bad way to reviewers I say that
because I just not good at it
um but yeah that's a spirit of that well
I will see you guys next week